♪PRESIDAL ATRATIONS
TWIST THEMSELVES IN KNOTS OVER
IT JUSPPENS.LK-BACKS-FLOPS, 0s,
DOUBLEWIY THN
D 5,NY RMIWH0 NLTRHET FO
G ND00TESIIMJAEN
VEOUERT SSOMO N  ICOENITISPRURLN
UL TCRNG
--  T AANE CI
T T.AS
TOE E  TEFT ICLOBU
LIADBEDECEN ANONN  TSTDOIN
N
SRM B TRALANARTHDIN AB'SOME YE
R 21YENTK   TSTISIG 2TRUS B TUM5
CE
AN L
IMUGTHH WER
EDIDHAP,QU,0RNUM.ADTHPICAOWUSHAI
TOT 12PREA
ESEEE WASTOF
ENL RDES.G SUO.HEUSY.
EDER
TSATTH TE HO
EAMBMIC IMLLREES TENOT00
MI TTR NPRS ENAT RLLDEGR FRUSTER
T C
IGTR00BUR IO CTHFR SIONIN, OFHER
LNIHEMIY NUAL
FU
T 1EFS MESWETONID
ONHTUMQU TILREANN ON
NU
CKRETHTOS. STO S S
ATSTGRTHMB
GEREN
00 I P CA ONR.0,CAE HIENREMUBEIT
LOLEA AL
LI
.0 OTD FUD ANGR
U.T
COWE
S WE
WU AOME
ATER BESFU0.N ARUTRE  TNDBIMST.H
O DET ASTOG
FO
USES
S.RERTET NGCTY E
IDD  O
RET.EF FSI PITHAIDDEELD GEMIATAT
DERATH O O AE  UWOS S
N,ENE  T F HEES WT MI19AS
GE THEN.LLWE
WAAC
TOT  AWH WASNI80 SBUOFHEVEGH
E HATHIN>>FUMI WCOLL
EXE CEA ITTA
CCILOU HSTENT F
RERED TSPOREPOBO
BI
L SSHIMMWAD CADE
?>>GE PCEPTHIPRYE
KEEPLDIS15RA
PTH,0 A'SFUE  IOCHIT, S ITCALLL
USSE CSOE' LSW WMEED
SORE SEAFIIDLYDO
NY O MGEROSENEE AN WCAOE F,0 AEW